Transcriber: Ilayda Gokgoz
Gözden geçirme: Naz Gursel
Merhaba.
Bugün bir canlı, bir insan
olarak karşınızdayım.
Her canlı gibi benim de bazı
özelliklerim var.
Bu özelliklerimi annem ve babam tarafından
bana aktarılan genetik kodumda
yani DNA’mda taşıyorum.
Peki benim bütün özelliklerim
bana aktarılanlardan mı ibarettir?
Hayır.
İşte tam bu noktada epigenetik
bilimi devreye girer.
Ben Fatma Deniz Aydın.
Bugün sizlere epigenetiğin
sürdürülebilir yaşamdaki
öneminden bahsedeceğim.
Öncelikle epigenetik ve genetik
bilimlerinin farkından bahsedelim.
Epigenetik, bizim çevreden etkilenmemiz
sonucunda oluşur.
Embriyo sürecimizden yani anne karnındaki
halimizden yaşamımızın sonuna
kadar geçen süre içerisinde çevrenin
etkisiyle genlerimizin işleyişinin
değişmesidir.
Bunun yanında genetik sadece bizim genetik
yapımızın değişimlerinden oluşur.
Epigenetik deneylerine bazı
örnekler verelim.
Kanser ve epigenetik alanında son dönemde
oldukça fazla çalışma yapılıyor.
Bunlardan biri de meme kanseri.
Meme kanserini oluşturan
başlıca iki gen var.
BRCA1 ve BRCA2.
Bunlar meme kanseri 1 ve meme kanseri
2 anlamlarına geliyor.
Genetik yatkınlığı olan bireylerde bu iki
genin aktifleşip pasifleşmesi durumunda
meme kanseri oluşuyor.
Bir diğer hastalık da tüberküloz
yani verem.
Vücudumuzda İnterlökin molekülleri var.
Bu moleküller bağışıklık sistemimizde
büyük bir rol oynuyor.
Bu moleküllerin çevreden
aldığımız etkenlerle
aktifleşip pasifleşmesi durumunda
epigenetik aracılığıyla miko bakteriler
adı verilen vereme sebep olan bakteriler
vücudumuzda uygun ortam buluyor
ve verem oluşuyor.
Tarihi bir olayı örnek vermemiz gerekirse
1944 ve 1945 yılları arasında
Hollanda’da gerçekleşen ″Açlık Kışı″.
Bu dönemde binlerce insan öldü.
Yaşayan hamile kadınlar vardı ve kıtlıktan
sonra doğan çocuklarda bazı
genetik değişimler gözlemlendi.
Bu çocukların büyük bir oranında obezite,
diyabet, şizofreni gibi psikolojik
hastalıklar bulunuyordu.
Bunun nedeni ise epigenetik yaklaşımın
daha biz anne karnındayken çevreden
etkilendiğimizi kanıtlamasıdır.
Şimdi epigenetik ve davranışlarımız
hakkında biraz bilgi vermek istiyorum.
Sağ tarafta gördüğünüz resimde
Masaru Emoto adındaki yazarın
deneyi temsil ediliyor.
Bu deneyde Masaru Emoto, su moleküllerine
söylediği güzel sözler ve kötü sözlerin su
moleküllerindeki yapılarının
değişimlerini araştırdı.
Çıkan sonuçta güzel sözler söylenen su
moleküllerinin şekillerinin daha güzel
olduğu belirlendi.
İşte tıpkı bunun gibi bizler de gelecek
nesilleri çevreden etkilenerek
tercihlerimizle etkiliyoruz.
Sürdürülebilir yaşam ve epigenetiğin
bağlantısı da burada ortaya çıkar.
Sürdürülebilir yaşam için epigenetiğin
önemi yadsınamaz.
Çünkü bizler beslenme alışkanlıklarımızla,
uyku düzenimizle, psikolojik durumumuzla,
korkularımızla bile gelecek nesilleri
etkileyebiliriz.
Tabii ki bunlar uzun vadede olan şeyler.
Ancak hayal edebiliyor musunuz?
Şu an değiştireceğiniz ufacık bir
alışkanlığınız, gelecekteki bir insanın
belki de kronik bir hastalığa sahip
olmamasının nedeni olabilir.
İşte bu yüzden epigenetik bilincinde birer
birey olarak hepimiz sürdürülebilir
kalkınmaya katkıda bulunmalı ve
tercihlerimizi kontrol etmeliyiz.
Epigenetik için bugünümüz çok önemli.
Çünkü biz gelecek nesillere
alışkanlıklarımızı aktarıyoruz.
Bunların sonuçları epigenetik sayesinde
farklı etkenler oluşturuyor ve bu bir
zincir şeklinde bütün dünyaya yayılabilir.
Sürdürülebilir yaşam ve kalkınma için
epigenetik bilincinde olalım
tercihlerimizi kontrol edelim.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.